[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 3 novembre bienvenue dans
le journal de tv 78 20 minutes 26
minutes même aujourd'hui pour faire le
tour de l'actualité locale voici les
titres de cette édition
après la rentrée de l'ensemble des
élèves hier c'était au tour des
collégiens du bois d'aulne de revenir en
classe aujourd'hui à conflans sainte
honorine 18 jours après l'assassinât du
professeur samuel patty est encore bien
sûr dans toutes les têtes nous étions
sur place est les bénévoles de cette
association était d'ailleurs mobilisé
pendant plusieurs jours à conflans
sainte honorine suite à l'attentât la
protection civile des yvelines est en ce
moment sur tous les fronts du
département celui notamment de la lutte
contre l'épidémie de kobe de 10,9 dont
la deuxième vague dévastatrice et avec
le confinement le gouvernement incite
les entreprises à recourir massivement
au télétravail à saint quentin en
yvelines les sociétés concertent en
moyenne et 10% de leurs salariés en
présentiel reportages et nous parlerons
tout à l'heure également de la
mobilisation des communes dans ce
nouveau confinement elles sont au
contact direct des populations et des
commerces notamment exemple à saint
germain en laye avec un plan de soutien
local qui est proposée par la commune
[Musique]
à conflans sainte honorine les élèves
ont repris ce mardi le chemin du collège
du bois d'aulne les jeunes ont été
accueillis par niveau tout au long de la
journée entre 8h et 16h un périmètre de
sécurité a été dressé par les forces de
l'ordre autour de l'établissement sur
place beaucoup d'émotion forcément
parents enfants et enseignants ont
toujours en tête l assassinat du
professeur d'histoire géographie
samuel pâtit survenu le 16 octobre
dernier et des psychologues étaient
présents pour permettre à tous
d'échanger et de mettre des mots sur ce
tragique événement réaction de parents
d'élèves qui a accompagné ce matin leurs
enfants au collège c'était au micro de
justin brasil très compliqué très très
très compliqué j'ai je me cache pas j'ai
une boule au ventre j'ai très peur aussi
comme mes enfants ils ont très peur mais
j'essaie de pas leur montrer ne pas leur
communiquer ma peur
malheureusement ils reprennent l'école
et ils vont vivre avec ça ils vont vivre
avec ça ils vont grandir avec ça ils
vont se construire avec ça je reste
assez calme mais les forces de l'ordre
qui sont de partout donc c'est plutôt
rassurant
et puis j'ai tendance à penser que ce
qui arrive une fois va pas se reproduire
au même endroit donc quelque part voilà
je suis plutôt plutôt tranquille hasni
voilà après j'espère que c'est plus les
enfants j'espère qu'ils vont pas trop
perturbé par tout ce qui se passe en une
minute de silence a été observée dans
l'établissement en hommage à samuel pâti
au sortir de cette matinée juste in
brazil a pu rencontrer un collégien qui
revient sur cette rentrée forte en
émotions c'était triste c'était froid
très calme les personnes qui parlaient
on a parlé du drame qui s'est passé
vendredi
ben yahia des professeurs qui ont pleuré
quand on a parlé pendant cours il y
avait des élèves aussi qu'ils vont
commencer à pleurer c'était vraiment en
cours très dur on va dire j'avais comme
professeur d'histoire
l'histoire jury de mc c'était un prof
très souriant il nous faisait des
blagues en fin de course pour pas qu'on
sorte nerveux du court et il faisait
toujours vivre ses cours en nous
demandant notre opinion et notre avis
donc du coup il nous faisait ouvrir un
autre esprit critique comme moi c'est
s'est passé on va dire enfin là j'étais
plus heureux de retrouver mes camarades
mes amis etc alors du court on va devoir
faire avec maintenant de façon ça va
être comme ça toute l'année et puis
surtout je pense que ce qui va être le
plus compliqué c'est de ces deux accepté
de nouveau remplaçant parce que ça va
être des cours différents de sa façon du
coup ça va être compliqué de s'y faire
beaucoup d'émotion à conflans sainte
honorine depuis l'attentât du 16 octobre
dernier en invité par visio à présent
c'est valérie so joe qui est avec moi
bonsoir vous êtes la directrice de la
formation et vice-présidente de la
protection civile des yvelines et
bénévoles de la protection civile ont
été dépêchées très vite sur place
après l'attentât pour assurer notamment
les cellules de soutien psychologique
des collégiens des collègues aussi de
samuel pâtit vous avez assisté notamment
le samu dans la cellule d'urgence
médico-psychologique quelles étaient vos
missions dans cette cellule oui alors
tout d'abord ce qu'il faut expliquer
c'est qu'en fait nous les déclencher la
demande du préfet des yvelines pour
venir en aide en effet la cellule
d'urgence médico psychologique donc un
cadre de permanence est envoyé pour voir
un peu pour faire l'état des lieux de ce
qui a besoin et donc là dans le cas de
conflit nous avons mis en place un
secrétariat qui permettait en fait au
samu de savoir combien de personnes il
avait en attente je dirais pour les
recevoir
et puis nous avons mis en place aussi
tout à un processus de dead
d'alimentation et puis une salle de
repos puisque les gens qui attendaient
ont leur permettait de boire un café un
chocolat il savait gâteau au chocolat
autres ainsi que pour d'ailleurs les les
membres de la cub et puis une salle de
repos dans le cas où quelqu'un ne se
sentirait pas bien les tubes c'est juste
la cellule d'urgence
médico-psychologique ont précisé les
termes et sept salles de repos dont vous
parliez c'est ce qu'on appelle
centre d'accueil des impliqués c'est ça
tout à fait alors je vais juste vous
rappeler le à quoi sert une coupe c'est
en fait c'est assurer la prise en charge
des victimes qui ont été confrontés un
élément psycho traumatisant donc ce sont
des gens qui sont formés qui son médecin
psychiatre ou psychologue avec des
infirmiers et des gens formés à ça et
qui font partie en fait c'est une je
dirais une sous partie du samu aux fins
du service médical des dominicaines
d'urgence voilà alors on l'a dit donc
une implication au sein de cette cubain
cette cellule d'urgence médico
psychologique du centre d'accueil des
impliqués on rappelle d'ailleurs les
trois missions de la protection civile
s'est aidé se courir formé l'aide
on en a parlé mais vous avez aussi
d'autres missions liées justement à
celle du secours sur place à conflans
sainte honorine
alors en fait on a décidé de mettre en
place un poste médical avancé léger en
accord avec la préfecture pour lors
qu'il y avait lors de rassemblements de
personnes devant le collège dans le cas
où il aurait eu là bas où un mouvement
de foule ou des gens trop série qui ne
se sentiraient pas bien avec du matériel
de secours pour venir en aide puisque
c'est aussi notre notre activité le
secours à personne donc une aide sur
place pour ses besoins en secourisme à
conflans sainte honorine y aussi
d'autres communes un des yvelines ont
fait appel aussi à la protection civile
qui a eu des rassemblements aussi dans
d'autres communes des yvelines
à l'occasion de cet hommage à samuel
pâtit l'hommage où il ya eu en fait la
marche entre le collège et la place à
conflans sainte honorine
nous avons assuré le dps chez nous c'est
pas un dispositif vauzelle de secours
l'ajustement pour le cas où il aurait vu
des personnes victimes blessées alors
l'aide psychologique donc oui à l'essai
au pardon excusez moi après nous avons
participé quand nous en avions la
possibilité aux différents hommages qui
ont été rendus au sein du département
il y en a eu plusieurs notamment dans
des grandes villes du département
versailles poissy notamment l'aide
psychologique dont on a parlé
injustement à conflans-sainte-honorine
au travers de cette
de ce centre d'accueil d'aidé impliqué
alors cette même action a été déployé à
poissy puisque il ya eu un autre
événement malheureux à poissy c'est
l'effondrement d'un mur au gymnase cas
lyonnais qui a causé la mort d'une
petite fille le 29 octobre dernier
ça c'est primordial s'est déployé très
vite à chaque fois c'est ce genre de
dispositif sur place alors encore une
fois voilà nous avons une relation
privilégiée avec la mairie voici donc
nous avons été prévenus immédiatement
aussi par la préfecture
donc nous avons dépêché notre cadre de
permanence pour voir quel était le
matériel et le nombre de personnes à
mettre en place et s'est avéré que le
rôle de la protection civile a été
d'accueillir avec paris les parents
permettre aux enfants d'avoir un goûter
et de se divertir puisque nous dans
notre matériel
il y à des jouets des livres différentes
composantes
selon le type de crise donc voilà en
fait l'administratif était déjà en place
par la cub et nous nous avons en fait
accueilli des parents les rassurer
prendre soin des enfants et puis bah
voilà alors permettre un peu de d'avoir
une vraie un changement de situation
pour pouvoir plus facilement intégré
malheureusement ce qui s'était passé
l'autre actualité qui mobilise bien sûr
vos bénévoles c'est l'épidémie de covile
19 avant de vous poser une question
quelques éléments déjà la france et les
ivy nancéens qui sont confrontés à une
deuxième vague si on regarde ces
derniers chiffres taux d'incidence qui
est certes en baisse dans le département
mais qui reste à un niveau bien élevés
tous les autres données toutes les
autres données sont à la hausse est très
inquiétant en ce qui concerne l'hôpital
83,8 % des lits de réanimation sont
occupés sont occupés en ile-de-france en
trente trois hospitalisations 29 décès
supplémentaires ont été enregistrées en
une semaine dans les hôpitaux yvelinois
les hôpitaux ça c'est une autre
information qui doivent faire face à
cette deuxième vague qui se réorganise à
rambouillet par exemple 31 patients
qu'ovide sont accueillis en ce moment
l'unité de gériatrie gériatrie est
désormais entièrement dédié aux malades
du coronavirus et l'hôpital va désormais
accueillir toutes les opérations
chirurgicales qui était programmé au
centre hospitalier andré mignot le site
du chéné rocancourt dédié à désormais
c'est trois blocs opératoires aux
patients hospitalisés
pour des formes graves de covin 19 alors
dans cette deuxième vague de kobe de 19
valérie so joe quels sont justement les
missions de la protection civile des
yvelines alors là nous avons une demande
comment fait on a eu lors de la du
premier confinement de participer aux
gars de sa mue un coq vide donc à
travers de deux éléments donc un premier
mise en place d'un véhicule de secours
un type ambulants sont comme les
sapeurs-pompiers qui va nous servir en
fait à aller à la demande du samu
chercher des patients qui pourraient
être qu'ovide et puis un véhicule léger
qui permettra de faire ce qu'on appelle
nous la levée de doute c'est à dire être
faire un bilan de la victime pour savoir
si potentiellement elle pourrait être
atteinte du coc vide ou pas afin de ne
pas faire déplacer les secours ont tiré
plus plus complet en tout cas plus
équipés de transport inutilement voilà
oui pardon non non non c'était donc vous
indiquer qu'il ya une réunion qui va
être mis en place
justement avec les samu pour permettre
cette organisation alors bien évidemment
ça n'attire pas que la protection civile
mais toutes les associations de sécurité
civile qui pourront y participer
justement j'allais vous demander dans ce
contexte vous parliez du salut on
imagine la coordination primordial c'est
il ya des réunions des rencontres entre
les différents services de secours tout
à fait alors au niveau départemental
notre interlocuteur privilégié est
encore une fois bas le samu bien
évidemment mais on a aussi la rs1
puisque c'est quand même le l'entité qui
va chapeauter tout ce domaine et puis
alors pour un autre une autre partie
mais qui aussi importants puisque nous
assurons des maraudes pour les gens sont
deux sans domicile a contacté avec la
ddcs pour permettra aux gens qui n'ont
malheureusement pas d'accueil fixe de
pouvoir bénéficier toujours de maraudes
pour les aider et comment vous l'abordez
ce nouveau confinement vous qui avez eu
justement l'expérience de la première
vague de ce premier confinement comment
les bénévoles de la protection civile
abortive alors sereinement parce que on
l'a déjà vécu donc on n'a pas la
surprise je dirais que les monts
surprise n'est plus vraiment présent
et avec énormément d'inquiétude parce
que ça risque de durer dans le temps
et comme beaucoup d'associations nous
sommes des bénévoles
là en ce moment je suis un bon travail
par exemple donc ça veut dire que notre
disponibilité mais je pense réduite d'où
la difficulté souvent pas de pouvoir
assurer ses missions qui sont vitales
qui sont importantes pour nous comme
pour le samu vis-à-vis de la population
bien évidemment mais on va avoir
énormément de soucis pour trouver des
bénévoles et c'est important de le
rappeler vous l'avez dit c'est une
association la protection civile avec
une place centrale pour les bénévoles
combien sont sont mobilisés dans les
yvelines est ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui des besoins en bénévoles
c'est l'occasion de passer un appel sur
notre antenne tout à fait à ce jour nous
avons soixante et onze bénévoles alors
dans les 60 bénévoles sont des
secouristes donc des gens qui sont
formés au secourisme en équipe
voilà qui est sur les dispositifs de
secours nous avons 13
réservistes donc les réserves et ce sont
des gens qui lors de la première dent
lors du premier confinement ont trouvé
un intérêt à porter non pas ce court
mais aide à la population
donc ce qu'il était souvent ces gens là
sur l'accueil de l'hôpital de poissy ou
de menthe et là en fait ils vont être
affectés particulièrement à une
logistique a été mis en place au niveau
de la protection civile nationale qui se
fera auprès des mairies des ccas des
bailleurs sociaux qui s'appelle
solidarité elle est en fait c'est un
logiciel qui va permettre de recenser
toutes les personnes qui ont des besoins
lors souvent personnes à mobilité
réduite ou personnes les seniors ou des
personnes âgées on va dire et notre rôle
ça va être de les suivre de les aider
par exemple s'ils peuvent pas se
déplacer pour aller chercher des
médicaments qui ont des problèmes pour
les soins des problèmes par rapport aux
repas notre rôle sera de les suivre
d'aller les voir s'il ya besoin donc de
le rapporter ou les repas ou des
médicaments et surtout de faire remonter
aux entités responsables ski où est le
problème et c'est trouver des solutions
pour prendre contact avec une maman oui
voilà donc l'afghane évidemment le
maximum de personnes nous permettra de
mettre à disposition ce qu'on peut pour
pour les différentes communes qui est
particulièrement celles qui n'ont pas
obligatoirement un gros ccas où beaucoup
de personnes pour gérer ce domaine et
donc toutes les bonnes volontés sont les
bienvenues bien évidemment et pour vous
prend propre prendre contact avec vous
je vais y arriver
le site internet de la protection des
civils des yvelines qui s'est affichée
il envoie un message à contacter le site
qui s'affiche on peut aussi faire des
dons un pur et des biens sur la
protection civile dans ses missions
merli merci valérie so joe d'avoir été
avec nous avec plaisir à jouer
merci directrice de la formation et
vice-présidente de la protection des
civils la protection civile j'oublie le
civil des yvelines on parle ensemble de
la deuxième vague de colis de 19 il
n'est pas impossible que le
gouvernement prenne des mesures
complémentaires pour tenter d'endiguer
l'épidémie remettre en place notamment
un couvre feu dès 21h à paris et dans
toute l'île de france
en plus du confinement déjà effectif le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent a annoncé l'instauration de ce
couvre feu dès aujourd'hui mais dans la
journée matignon a démenti et indiqué
que pour l'heure rien n'était acté
l'hypothèse est seulement évoqué pour
forcer les commerces à fermer dès 21h
[Musique]
avec le nouveau confinement les
entreprises aussi doivent s'adapter
reprendre une activité majoritairement
en télétravail c'est le souhait du
gouvernement affichée lors des dernières
prises de parole du premier ministre
jean castex à saint quentin en yvelines
les sociétés se sont très vite adaptés
les précisions de nicolas dandois elles
sont nombreuses à pouvoir poursuivre
leurs activités en télétravail les
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
majoritairement dans le secteur
tertiaire ont remis en place cette
organisation spécialisée dans les
services de stockage informatique et de
cyber sécurité
antemeta a décidé de mettre 110
personnes en télétravail sur les 180
employés du site de guyancourt
on a pris la décision avec l'ensemble
des membres du comité de direction de
généraliser le télétravail en assurant
une permanence pour les activités qui
d'être continuer notamment d'origine
commercial et d'importants surcoûts il
maintenant chez nos clients pensent que
dans tous les cas le télétravail
enfin en tout cas le confinement change
les méthodes de travail pour l'avenir et
que le télétravail va forcément devenir
une petite d'en bas en tout cas dans les
entreprises et nous on constate déjà
même dans nos entretiens de recrutement
qui effectivement l'école les candidats
nous pose la question
autre exemple avec d link france son
siège est installé dans le quartier de
l'hyper centre de montigny le bretonneux
aujourd'hui sur la vingtaine de
collaborateurs 17 poursuivre leurs
activités depuis leur domicile
il reste malgré tout des besoins de 30
ans de d'être au pureau on n'est pas
dans le même confinement que le premier
confinement le premier confinement
l'activité s'était réduite de façon
assez importante
là c'est pas le cas pour l'instant donc
qu'elle ait besoin d'être bureau parfois
elles sont en soins vers ie au cepsum
produits etc
du côté du technocentre renault le
télétravail est aussi la règle seulement
10% des onze mille salariés sont
actuellement présents sur le site
leur présence est nécessaire de par leur
mission l'activité sur des prototypes
sur des bancs d'essai ou les projets
urgents sur de futurs véhicules
avant ce nouveau confinement depuis le 7
septembre 2020 les collaborateurs du
technocentre télétravail et trois ou
quatre jours par semaine
al'annonce du confinement plusieurs
commune yvelinoise ont décidé de mettre
de remettre en place des actions à
saint-germain-en-laye la commune a
choisi de lancer un plan local de
soutien plan local spécifique
explications dans cette interview
express réalisé par mélanie poker on a
décliné un plan de soutien en trois
temps en trois composantes évidemment un
plan de soutien économique un plan de
soutien sanitaire et puis surtout un
plan de soutien qu'on a appelé la
solidarité de proximité et donc cette
semaine dans les plus de 20 mille boîtes
aux lettres de la ville nous allons
déposer des questionnaires et bien
entendu les annonces du président dupré
ministres et des médecins disant qu'ils
font surtout que les plus fragiles
restent à l'écart se protègent restent
chez eux le plus possible on sait que
c'est pas toujours facile il faut rompre
aussi cette logique d'isolement auxquels
peuvent être confrontés nos aînés
sur les locaux dont nous sommes
titulaires
voilà on a fait des franchises de loyer
on a été au rendez vous on a fait des
exonérations on a fait exor énormément
d'exonération de droit de théâtre on
permet bien évidemment la vente a
rapporté donc c'est on a permis à ces
poulets et commerces donc on a aussi des
permanences
on va mettre en place avec l'ensemble
des élus on a de la chance d'avoir des
élus experts sur la question on a
notamment à l'ancienne prison de la
chambre de commerce des yvelines qui est
là il faut cherche donc on va faire des
guichets d'accueil pour recenser les
difficultés pour après les orienter sur
les mécanismes dead on va organiser très
certainement une médiation autour des
loyers commerciaux parce que c'est leur
sujet voilà moi le le crédit d'impôt qui
a été voté qui a été décidé par le
gouvernement à hauteur de 30% à moi le
voyez ça suffit pas il faut aller au
delà et là il faut véritablement que
nous ont pu jouer notre rôle
d'intermédiation entre les propriétaires
et les locataires
on va les mettre en place en fin de
semaine on a acheté nous mêmes des tests
antigénique alors qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait déjà on va alimenter la médecine de
ville
ils auront comme ça en stock avec des
patients asymptomatiques qui viennent
les voir il faut que ce soit réservé
vraiment patients symptomatiques
c'est vraiment très important que dans
les yvelines certains maires ont décidé
d'aller contre les décisions
gouvernementales c'est le cas à maisons
laffitte et aussi à limay le maire
communiste
eric rouleau a pris un arrêté pour
maintenir ouvert l'ensemble des
commerces dans la commune y compris ceux
non essentiels qui doivent pourtant
restée fermée avec le confinement l'élu
justifie cette décision par la volonté
d'égalité de traitement entre les
petites boutiques et la grande
distribution
l arrêté municipal pourrait cependant
être vite annulée par le tribunal
administratif de versailles lé marché en
revanche peuvent cette fois ci restait
ouvert continuer leur activité ce qui
n'était pas le cas pendant le premier
confinement une décision accueillie avec
soulagement par les professionnels
présents dans une centaine de marchés
dans les yvelines un reportage au marché
notre dame de versailles avec mélanie
poquet eléonore sinoquet et bixente n'a
rien senti steban un soulagement du côté
des clients et des commerçants pour ce
second confinement les marchés sont
reconnus comme essentiel et ce dimanche
la pluie et le vent les clients sont
restés fidèles c'était vraiment dur au
premier confinement que tout soit fermé
surtout qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup de
grandes surfaces avec des produits frais
sympa autre que le marché ait vu qu'on
est vraiment à deux pas c'est un peu la
petite sortie du week-end qui est assez
sympa je suis assez favorable pour au
moins ce marché de produits frais puisse
ouvrir puisse être activé
d'abord pour le client qui est
nécessaire de pouvoir y avoir des
produits frais il faut quand même penser
aussi aux commerçants
le marché s'est quand même ouvert je
crois que chacun fait attention
c'est ça me semblait plus logique de le
laisser ouvert en avril dernier
seuls les halles avait pu rouvrir grâce
à une dérogation obtenue par la ville
pour ce deuxième confinement les étals
ont été adaptés les stands sont bâchées
font la demande de la mairie de
versailles
on demande aux gens de ne pas toucher
mais vous en moins de la clientèle bien
longtemps qu'ils sont éduqués dans le
coeur une pige pas aujourd'hui tout le
monde est équipé de masques nous avons
dû gel hydroalcoolique à disposition
pour l'ensemble de nos deux de nos
clients et pour nous mêmes
après chacune de transactions nous nous
des affectant les mains la plupart du
temps on prend on manipule également
l'ensemble de nos produits avec des
gants pour éviter cette transmission
sauf nouvelle décision gouvernementale
les marchés devraient rester ouverts
pendant toute la durée du confinement
la ville de versailles n'en compte pas
moins de cinq pour l'alimentaire
adaptation dans les marchés adaptation
aussi du côté des collectivités qui ont
dû se réorganiser suite à l'annoncé de
la mesure du confinement exemple à saint
quentin en yvelines l'ensemble des
médiathèques de l'agglomération le musée
de la ville à montigny le bretonneux est
la commanderie à elancourt et la piscine
high end et des clayes-sous-bois sont
bien sûr fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre mais
des services continue tout de même de
fonctionner elle les collectes des
déchets ménagers se poursuivent les
calendriers de passage sont à consulter
sur les sites internet des communes les
sept déchetteries saint-quentinoise
reste ouverte tout comme le ski tube
située à vue en cours celle incubateur d
entreprises l institut de promotion de
la santé la maison de justice et de
droit à trappes maintiennent un accueil
du public maintient également d'un
accueil à la résidence
jean fourcassa la résidence pour
personnes âgées 1 qui reste ouverte
pendant confinement enfin l'hôtel
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines assurera lui
un accueil téléphonique pendant toute la
durée du confinement du lundi au
vendredi et de 8h30 à 12h30 et de 13h15
à 17h15 attention le vendredi la
permanence s'arrêtera à 16h15 et tout
déplacement même dans les services de la
collectivité doivent se faire mais ni
d'une attestation
et puis avant de refermer ce journal ce
secteur d'avenir avec des promesses de
débouchés celui de la fibre optique
selon une étude portée par le ministère
du travail le nombre d'emplois sera de
22 mille le nombre d'emplois qui seront
nécessaires ce sera 22 milles en 2021
dans cette branche dans les yvelines
plusieurs partenaires se sont associés
pour former les futurs techniciens le
groupe tdf l'opérateur cnmv numérique ou
encore l' agence activity mélanie poquet
intervention d'urgence pour d'audi et
vincent le réseau très haut débit sur ce
secteur connaît quelques problèmes
ils travaillent tous les deux pour spir
entreprise spécialisée notamment dans
les réseaux de communication moi je vais
de du monde du sport et du football en
particulier et donc du coup j'ai eu du
mal à appliquer ces domaines parce que
je cherchais vraiment un métier
captivant et ce métier j'ai trouvé grâce
à la fibre c'est un métier à
responsabilité oui c'est un métier aussi
d'avenir et lors de la présentation de
la fibre optique le simple fait de
savoir qu'aujourd'hui grâce à un tube en
verre on peut on a la possibilité
d'avoir l'internet la télévision la
téléphonie cela m'a beaucoup motivé un
métier qu'ils ont appris grâce à
plusieurs mois de formation en
alternance ils ont ensuite été engagé en
contrat à durée indéterminée par
l'entreprise l'avantagent que nous avons
informé ses collaborateurs et les
embauches et derrière c'est qu'ils
connaissent ensuite le fonctionnement de
l'entreprise et il s'immerge beaucoup
plus facilement au sein de l'entreprise
au fonctionnement une insertion pensé
par plusieurs partenaires seine et
yvelines numériques et tdf en charge du
déploiement de la fibre dans les zones
rurales
il n'est noise cent mille foyers dans
150 localités le marché de déploiement
de la fibre c'est un marché dans lequel
il ya de la tension c'est à dire qu'il
ya un manque cruel de compétences et de
nombreuses entreprises leur coach le
fait que yes et opportunités d'emploi
c'est une aubaine pour que
des publics qui rencontrent des
difficultés d'accès à la formation et à
la vo travail puisse intégrer ce
parcours identifiés par des agences
d'insertion comme activités en recherche
d'emploi dodier vincent ont suivi une
formation de deux ans qu'ils ont
terminée en juin dernier
reconversion professionnelle suite de
ces ap une vingtaine de jeunes et formés
chaque année à l'école
ea ea québec à aubergenville dans notre
école les a c'est le coeur nous formons
que des jeunes en apprentissage en
alternance
nous pouvons donc accueillir des jeunes
de tout âge car l'alternance peut être
concilié pour des jeunes de moins de 30
ans nous pouvons même former des
personnes d'une quarantaine d'années est
au contraire c'est d'autant plus
bénéfique pour notre école et pour
l'insertion professionnelle démarré il
ya trois ans ce programme de formation
atteint chaque année un taux d'insertion
de 100%
c'est la fin de ce journal de demain
vous retrouverez eléonore sinoquet pour
une nouvelle édition belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]